[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
ليث وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه اللقطات من العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو مع الحديث عن اجراءات امنيه
مستمره بعد الاعلان عن انتهاء ازمه مجموعه
اما هذه الصور فتاتي مباشره من العاصمه
اليونانيه اثنا وترقب لنتائج النهائيه
للانتخابات العامه هناك وحديث عن تصدر حزب
رئيس الوزراء الحديث
اما هذه الصور فتاتي من مكه المكرمه عشيه
توجه حجاج بيت الله الحرام غدا الى مشعرنا
لقضاء يوم التربيه
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد انتهاء ما وصفها الكريم بازمه التمرد
مقاتلون مجموعه باجنر يستكملون عودتهم الى
قواعدهم وموسك تبقي على اجراءاتها الامنيه
بعد اعلان عمدتها تفعيل نظام مكافحه
الارهاب وفي تعليق امريكي لينكن يشكك في
انتهاء الاضطرابات في روسيا ويقولون اخر
فصولها لم ياتي بعد
وفي انعكاسات ازمه بادنر على الحرب في
اوكرانيا
القوات الاوكرانيه تكثف هجماتها على جبهات
الشرق وتقول انها استعاده مساحات في شمال
ضخمه وجنوبها وفي روايه مضاده القوات
الروسيه تؤكد صد الهجمات باتجاه المدينه
ومناطق اخرى في جبهه دنيا
في السودان الجيش يقول انه قصف تجمعات
للدعم السريع في محيط مقر شرطه الاحتياطي
المركزي جنوبي الخرطوم بعد اعلان قوات
الدم سيطرتها عليه
وفي ارتدادات المعارك على الوضع الانساني
اعلانا عن نزوح ثمانيه ملايين ولجوء نصف
مليون اخرين منذ بدء النساء
غارات المكثفه على الشمال السوري توقع
قتلى وجرحى فصائل المعارضه تقول ان
مقاتلات روسيه قصفت ساسوقا للخضروات في
جسر الشغور ومحيط مدينه ادلب وقوه النظام
السوري تستهدف بالمدفعيه مناطق سكنيه في
سرمين
وفي لقاءنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا مالات الازمه بينر والجيش
الروسي والتي تركت اسئله كثيره بشان ما
بعدها وان كانت قد انتهت حقا ومالات ذلك
على روسيا وحربها في اوكرانيا لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي برايكم هل انتهت الازمه
المتعلقه بمجموعه في روسيا
30% قالوا ان الازمه انتهت اما سبعون في
المئه فتوقعوا موجات جديده لها
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
[موسيقى]
اذا مستمرون في حديثنا عن موضوع ازمه قوات
فاجنر في روسيا اذ تستكمل هذه القوات سحب
قوتها من المقاطعات التي انتشرت فيها
وتعود الى قواعدها فقد اكدت السلطات
مقاطعات لبيتسك الروسيه ان جميع وحدات
مجموعه فاجرا غادرت اراضي المقاطعه اما
حاكم مقاطعات
الروسيه فقال ان قوات بعد تنسحب من اراضي
المنطقه بشكل طبيعي دون اي حوادث واعلنت
سلطات المقاطعات روستوف وبورونيج وكالوجا
ولبيتس واقليم كراس نودار رفع القيود
المفروضه على حركه السير
اما في موسكو فقالت وكاله ان حركه المرور
عادت الى جميع الجسور التي اغلقت بالامس
في محيط العاصمه روسيا واضافت الوكاله ان
السلطات الروسيه ابقت على اجراءات مكافحه
الارهاب في المدينه وكانت وزاره النقل
الروسيه قصرت حركه المرور عبر نهر اوكا في
موسكو امس على ثلاثه جسور فقط قصرتها على
ثلاثه جسور كما اعلن عمده موسكو تفعيل
نظام مكافحه الارهاب في العاصمه الروسيه
لتعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه
اذا رغم حسمه بصفقه مع انهت الازمه فان
التحرك الاخير لشركه فاجنر خلف العديد من
التساؤلات بشان مصير هذه المجموعه التي
تلعب ادوارا كبيره لرعايه المصالح الروسيه
في عده دول حول العالم التطورات الاخيره
وضعت تحت المجهر تعاطي الكرملين مع ما قد
يهدد تماسك الجبهه الداخليه الروسيه
غادر قائد مجموعه فاغنرا الترابا الروسيه
نحو بيلاروسيا وغادرت قواته مقاطعه ارستوف
انتهت الازمه في ظاهرها فماذا بعد تسيطر
الاسئله الان بشان مصير مجموعه فاجنر
برمتها كشفت احداث السبت عما يعتقد انها
تصدعات في اهم اركان قوه بوتين وهو الهيكل
الامني والعسكري وتذهب التحليلات لقراءه
التطورات المحتمله من خلال صفقه الكريملين
مع بريجوجين بواسطه بيلاروسيا
فقد تضمنت عوده مقاتلي فاجنر الذين
اقتربوا من موسكو الى معسكراتهم مقابل
اغلاق القضيه الجنائيه بالتحريض على
التمرد المسلح بحق بريكوجين ومغادرته الى
بيلاروسيا وان لا يخضع اي من مقاتلي فاجنر
ممن شاركوا في الهجوم الاخير لاي ملاحقه
قانونيه بعد تسريحهم اما المقاتلون الذين
لم يشاركوا في حمله بريجوجين فيمكنهم
توقيع عقود مع وزاره الدفاع للانضمام الى
القوات المسلحه لا ينتهي كل شيء بتنفيذ ما
ورد في هذه الصفقه
اذ ما الذي يضمن عدم حدوث اضطرابات كهذه
مستقبلا كما توقع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
فقد ابدى استغرابه لعدم حدوث اقالات لقاده
عسكريين في روسيا لقد اثار مشهد عبور
ارتال من فاجنر من مقاطعه روستوف جنوبا
الى تخوم موسكو دون اعتراض اي من القوات
الامنيه او العسكريه اثار علامات استفهام
والتدابير الاستثنائيه التي اتخذتها
السلطات في موسكو تثير تساؤلات عن من يحمي
العاصمه والكرملين ومراكز القرار لقد كشفت
تحرك فاجنر عن شكوك في تماسك الجبهه
الداخليه الروسيه وباتت جبهات الحرب في
اوكرانيا امام تحد كبير ليس الامر مقتصرا
على هذا فهناك جبهات اخرى تنتشر فيها قوات
فاجنر لتكون اليد طول لروسيا في القاره
الافريقيه ينشط اكثر من خمسه عشر الف
مقاتل تابعين للمجموعه في دول افريقيه
ابرزها افريقيا الوسطى والسودان وليبيا
وبوركينا فاسو ومالي
فما مصير هذه القوات ومن سيديرها وهل
ستفكك موسكو ما توصف بذراعها الطوله ام
انها ستعيد هيكلتها بقياده جديده
وينضم الان الينا من موسكو الكساندر
ارتامونوف الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اهلا وسهلا بك في الحصاد اذا اسئله كثيره
اثرها التقرير ولكن يبقى السؤال الاساسي
هل انتهت الازمه
ان ازمه بريغوجين قد انتهت
الا انه سوف نحتاج للكثير من الوقت حتى
ننظر لجميع الجذور الذي ادت
للتمرد المسلح المساله الان الى اين ذهبت
وماذا سوف يعمل في بروسيا واين سوف يقع
هناك
والى اين سوف تذهب المعدات الثقيله هل
اخذها معه ام لا وهذه الاسئله يقوم بطرحها
الكثيرين من المراقبين والمحللين في موسكو
وحتى
الرئيس لهيئه الاركان البريطانيه السابق
يرى ان بريجوجين قد يحاول الهجوم على كيف
من بروسيا هل انتهت هذه الازمه لا استطيع
ان اقول
هذه اسئله تتعلق نفسه ولكن ماذا عما يتعلق
بالرئيس الروسي بوتين نريد ان نفهم موقفه
يعني هو القى خطابا ناريا بالامس ثم سامح
الجميع
هل مازال رجل روسيا القوي اليوم كيف تاثر
بهذه الازمه
استطيع ان اقول ان هذه الازمه اثبتت ان
المجتمع الروسي لم تدد المجتمع الروسي لم
يدعم التمرد المسلح ولم تدعم شركات
العسكريه الخاصه بل الكثير من الشركات
العسكريه الخاصه الاخرى لم تدعم فريجوجل
لذلك سلطان وقوه
بوتين والثقه به كل هذا لم يتضرر ولا باي
جانب من الجوانب بوتين هو شخص ذكي وهو
ثعلب
شمالي كما يسموه السياسيين وفي هذه الحاله
من المحتمل ان هذه الازمه سوف يستطيع
بوتين ان يحولها لمصلحته
وهو الان يثبت انه ليس حاكم
ظالم لذلك او او
انه يستطيع ان يستفيد من الظروف في مصلحته
انت تساءلت قبل قليل عن مستقبل قوات فاجنر
ومصيرها بعدما حدث ولكن ماذا عن المؤسسه
العسكريه هل تتوقع تغييرات في المؤسسه
العسكريه
اعتقد ان بعد ما حدث يجب ان يكون هناك
تغيرات لانه في نهايه اي ازمه تظهر
النقاط الضعف
واي ازمه تعني اننا هناك ما يجب ان نقوم
به لذلك سوف يكون هناك تغيرات تغيرات
سريعه اشكرك الكسندر ارتامونوف الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي من موسكو
وفي ردود الفعل من ثياب قلم مستشار
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخايلو بودلوياك ان
من المتوقع هبوب رياح جديده في روسيا في
اشاره الى احتمال تكرار الانقسامات واضاف
في تغريده عبر تويتر انما وصفها
بالكوميديا الماساويه التي حصلت في روسيا
تشرح لقاده العالم سبب عدم رؤيه اوكرانيا
اي فرصه للتفاوض مع روسيا متسائلا الى من
يمكن التحدث في منزل لا سيد له والجميع
يمسحون اقدامهم بالقياده العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه على حد وصفه واشار الى ان
الوضع في روسيا هش ولا يمكن السيطره عليه
اما امريكيا
فجاء تصريح وزير الخارجيه انتوني بلينكن
ليقول ان بلاده ليست لديها معلومات كامله
بشان ما حدث في روسيا لكنه اشار الى ان
اخر الفصول هذه الازمه لم تكتب بعد على حد
تعبيره واضاف بلان في مقابله مع شبكه سي
ان انما حدث غير عادي وانا هناك تصدعات لم
تكن موجوده من قبل في روسيا حسب تعبيره
ليست لدينا معلومات كامله ولا يزال الوقت
مبكرا لنقول بالضبط الى اين ستذهب الامور
فصوره متحركه ولم نرى الفصل الاخيره بعد
لكن يمكننا القول انما حدث غير عادي فقد
راينا تصدعات لم تكن موجوده من قبل قبل
سته عشر شهرا كانت القوات الروسيه على
اعتاب مدينه كييف معتقده انها ستسيطر على
المدينه في غضون ايام وستمحو اوكرانيا من
الخريطه اما الان فكان عليها التركيز على
موسكو ضد المرتزقه هذا يثير كثيرا من
الاسئله العميقه ستتم الاجابه عنها في
الايام والاسابيع المقبله
ينضم الان الينا من واشنطن السفير بيجي
كراولي المتحدثه السابق في الاسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
اذا بليكن يرى ان هناك تصدعات داخل روسيا
لم تكن موجوده من قبل الى ماذا يستند في
قول هذا
عرض فكره بوتين في احتلال اوكرانيا علنا
وانتقد القياده العسكريه والرئيسه نفسه
اذا هذا تحدي مباشر
وعلني لبوتين انا يمكن ان اقول انها اكبر
ازمه سياسيه في روسيا منذ 30 عاما
اكبر ازمه ولكن داخل روسيا على الاقل وهذا
ما يعلن يعتبرون انها انتهت
دوليا ربما يكون هناك راي اخر ولكن ما
تداعيات الحقيقيه التي سنشهدها على المدى
القصير والمدى البعيد لهذه الازمه
انت محقه لان
الاسماء المباشره يبدو انها تم ايقافها
ولكن في رايي انه في كل مره
كل مره التقى بوتين برؤساء قدم قائمه من
الماخذ
ولم يقبل
احرج بوتين
ويبدو الان انهم
اتفق انهم اتفق على هدنه ولكن هناك شك في
ان في وقت ما بوتين سوف يثار لنفسك ماذا
عن
ما يجري في اوكرانيا كيف سياثر هذا سواء
نافي بروجين الى بيلاروسيا
مصير فاجنر المؤسسه العسكريه اذا ما حصل
فيها تغيير كيف سيؤثر على مسار الحرف في
اوكرانيا
سؤال ممتاز مستقبل مجموعه
ودورها في اوكرانيا
ننتظر لنعرف كم من
اعضائه سوف يستمرون في القتال في اوكرانيا
وكم سوف يستمرون في معارضه
موسكو اذا هذا ينبغي ان ننتظر لنرى لكن
اعتقد انه في المدى القصير سوف يكون ذلك
في صالح اوكرانيا في كل مره هناك انقسام
في الخصم ذلك يكون عاملا مساعدا وهناك خطر
لاوكرانيا اذا اعترفوا
بوتين انه تم
تحديه وانه ربما
يشدد من
هجوماته على اوكرانيا حتى يعوض على
ما حدث كان هناك شيء من الاحتفاء في روسيا
بانتهاء الهجوم المضاد لصالح موسكو هل نحن
بصدد موجه جديده هل اختلف الامر تماما
الان
وسنشهد تحرك جديد من جانب اوكرانيا
ودعم اكبر من الغرب بهذا الخصوص
الوزير قال اليوم ان
الهجوم المضاد في مراحله الاولى
وان الدعم من الغرب ومن حلف الناتو سوف
يستمر
وانا لست متاكدا
ما الذي سيحدث
هل ان دفاعات روسيا ستكون اقوى ام اضعف
لكني اعتقد ان هذا النزاع ما يزال امامه
طريق طويل
المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا في الح
صان لكن خلال مقابلته مع شبكه سي ان ان
التي اشرنا اليها قبل القليل اشار في هذا
هذه المقابله الى الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
وقال انما حدث في روسيا وفر ميزه اضافيه
لاوكرانيا
هذه هي الايام الاولى للهجوم المضاد الذي
سيستمر على مدى اسابيع وربما اشهر
الاوكرانيون يملكون ما يحتاجون عليه
لتحقيق الانتصار الروس وضعوا الكثير من
الدفاعات خلال الاشهر الماضيه تحسبا لهذا
الهجوم المضاد لكنه يتقدم انشغال روسيا
وقلقه بوتين بشان ما يجري داخل البلاد
يوفران ميزه اضافيه للاوكرانيين للاستفاده
منها اوكرانيا تمضي قدما في هجومها المضاد
بغض النظر عن ذلك ولديها خطه واضحه
اذا بلينك المتحدثا بالفعل قالت القوات
الاوكرانيه انها تاخذ زمام المبادره في
منطقه بخموت وتهاجم القوات الروسيه واشار
المتحدث باسم القوات الاوكرانيه في الشرق
الاوسط
ان قواتي بلاده تقدمت بين 600 الى 1000
متر شمالي وجنوبي منطقه بخ
[موسيقى]
هذا ورصد مراسل الجزيره تحركات عسكريه
مكثفه للقوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه منطقه
بخموت في مقاطعه شرقيه اوكرانيا وقال
مراسل الجزيره الى القوات الاوكرانيه تعزز
مواقعها في المناطق الشماليه والجنوبيه من
منطقه بخمت
ما تشير اليه الخرائط هنا خرائط تحركات
القوات الاوكرانيه هو ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول ان تقوم بالاحاطه بمنطقه
بخموت لا تتقدم باتجاه المدينه في عمق
المدينه انما تحيط بمنطقه بخموت من
المنطقه الشماليه ومن المنطقه الشرقيه
مجددا نشاهد هذه التعزيزات هنا التي
تقوم القوات الاوكرانيه
ابقائي عليها وبالتوجه من هنا عبر منطقه
غربي باخمت باتجاه منطقه بخمو التعزيزات
كثيفه للغايه نشاهدها بشكل متواصل تتجه في
هذه الاثناء نحو منطقه باخموت استطيع ان
اقول وهنا ايضا نشاهد هؤلاء الذين يخرجون
ايضا من المنطقه اذا هناك حركه حركه نشطه
كما تشاهدون في هذه الاثناء من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه في محيط منطقه باكموت باتجاهها
ايضا بعد ما جرى في الداخل
الروسي بعد انسحاب قوات فاجنر من تلك
المنطقه
ورفضي هذه التحركات في القوات الاوكرانيه
المختلفه في محيط هذه الجبهه هذه الجبهه
عادت لتشتعل مجددا كما يبدو القوات
الاوكرانيه تعزز من مواقعها هناك
والتصريحات الرسميه تشير الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تتقدم بهذا الاتجاه
وللحديث عن تقدم الاوكراني في باخموت ردت
عليه القوات الروسيه بشبه نفي قائله انها
بتصدت للهجمات بحسب ما اعلن المتحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
قواتنا عشره هجمات للعدو في اتجاه دونيت
قرب بخموت في يوم واحد كما صدت 4 هجمات
اوكرانيه اخرى في دونيتسك في اتجاه جنوب
دونيتس صدت نيران المدفعيه وانظمه قاذفات
اللهب هجومين من قبل لواء الدفاع الاقليمي
128 في اتجاه زبولوجيا
وانطلاقا من هذا الحديث
تطرح اسئله عديده عن الدور المستقبلي
لقوات فاجنر في الجبهات وكيف سيتاثر
الاداء الروسي في المعارك
بينما كان
يزحف بقوته ومقاتله نحو موسكو كانت جبهه
القتال في اوكرانيا تعيش على وقع تحولات
متسارعه بشان القوات الاوكرانيه هجمات
المتزامنه على الجبهه الشرقيه وسط حديث
رسميا اوكراني عن احراز تقدم خصوصا شمال
وجنوب غرب باخموت وخوضها قتالا عنيفا على
طول جبهه زابولوجيا في التفاصيل تحدثت
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني عن هجوم
متزامن في ست بلدات شمال وجنوب باخموت
ابرزها
وبالقرب من كريشيفكا وكوردو جنوب غربي
بخموت ترد الدفاع الروسيه بصدد الهجمات
الاوكرانيه بالقرب من فاسليفك وتقع عشرين
كيلومترا شمال شرق باخموت وتصف بالفاشله
عمليه هجوميه اوكرانيه في اتجاهات جنوب
فالقوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه وصلت ايضا
هجمات بريه محدوده على طول جبهه افديفيكا
في دونيتسك بينما قالت الدفاع الروسيه ان
قوتها صدت هجمات اوكرانيه هناك
وقربايسكي ومالينكا لكن اكبر ما حققه
الاوكرانيون وفق قياده منطقه عمليات جنوب
الشرق اوكرانيا استعاده مواقع باتجاه
مدينه دانيت لم تعد تحت السيطرتهم منذ
2014 وتقع قرب كريسنو غريفيكا وتبعد نحو
12 كيلومترا عن دونيتسك قائد عمليه منطقه
شرق اوكرانيا تحدث ايضا عن تنفيذ ما وصفها
بالهجمات المدفعيه الممتازه في اتجاه
مقاطعه لوغانسك وهي جبهه اخرى لم تكن بنفس
ضرووه وتحرك المشهد كحل دونيتسك اذا على
جبهه وتحديدا ضخمه
وحتى لوغانسك ملامح وضع يريد الاوكرانيون
فرضه في سياق ما يسمونه الهجوم المضاد وسط
تساؤلات عن تاثير ما حدث من تطورات في
روسيا فاذا كان
ومقاتل فاجنر الفضل في السيطره الكامله
على مدينه سوليدار الاستراتيجيه في مقاطعه
الشرقيه اوكرانيا ولاحقا على بخموت فان
غياب هذه القوات او جزء منها يطرح اكثر من
تساؤل اقر رئيس مجموعه فاغنر المسلحه
بان حوالي عشره الاف من بين خمسين الف
سجين جندتهم فاجنر من السجون الروسيه
قتلوا على خط المواجهه في معركه بخموت
الداميه ونسبه مماثله من مقاتله محترفين
لقوا حتفهم ايضا في القتال ووفق الانباء
القادمه من روسيا فانه سيتم عرض عقود
عسكريه منتظمه على الضباط فاجنر الذين لم
يشاركوا في التمرد وسيتم من شاركوا فيه من
القتال واذا تم حل فاجنر فسيؤدي ذلك الى
حرمان روسيا من القوه العسكريه الاكثر
فاعليه في اوكرانيا وفق معهد الدراسات
الحرب
وبحسب المعهد نفسه فان تصرفات فاجنر اظهرت
افتقار روسيا للاحتياطيه في المناطق
الخلفيه والتمرد الذي حدث قد يعطل قدره
القوات الروسيه على الدفاع ضد الهجمات
المضاده الاوكرانيه لكن تحليلا لمعهد
ابحاث السياسه الخارجيه ومقره الولايات
المتحده شكك في ان يكون لتهميش جيش
بريكوجين تاثير كبير لكن موسكو قد تستخدم
تمر دافاجنر لتفسير الخسائر المستقبليه
حسب التحليل
[موسيقى]
وانضم الان الينا من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العميد الياس حنا اهلا وسهلا
بك عميد الياس اذا تحليلات كثيره بشان ما
جرى بالامس
واثار وتداعياته على الارض والسؤال كيف
ترى انت ما يجري على الارض الان على خلفيه
ما حصل بالامس فقط
ليلى اولا قوات فاجنر كانت خرجت من بخموت
وذهبت الى منطقه استراحه وبالتالي حصل
التمرد في الداخل الروسي يعني لم يكن لهذه
القوات تاثير في المرحله الحاليه ولكن على
الجبهه الحاليه او الجبهه بطول 900
كيلومتر التعزيزات والتموضع التكتيكي
للقوات الاوكرانيه هو على قدم وساق يعني
عمليه جس النبض عمليه البروبن كما يقال
حتى في مخموت وحتى في
اوريكيفولوجيا هي عمليه مستمره لجس النبض
لمعرفه اين سيقع الخلل اما تاثير موضوع 25
الف مقاتل هو شيء مهم ولكن القوات الروسيه
اليوم هي في حاله دفاع وقوات فاجنر تعتبر
قوات هجوميه
الافتقاد لها قد يكون فقط في عمليه
الاحتياط الهجومي
عمليات عكسيه او كاونتر اتاك كما يقال في
حال تم الخرق في مكان ما ولكن نحن ليلى في
مرحله جديده ديناميكيه مختلفه للحرب في
اوكرانيا
والحديث
من الجانب الامريكي على الاقل هو عن هجوم
مضاد ناجح وان اوكرانيا اليوم لديها كل ما
يلزم لتنفيذ هذا الهجوم الذي اعتقدنا في
وقت ما على الاقل حسب روايات موسكو انه
انتهى بفشل ذريع من الجانب الاوكراني الى
اي حد انقلبت الايه الان
اولا الهجوم في بداياته لم يكن فاشلا هذا
امر طبيعي لقوات روسيه كان لها وقت طويل
للاستعداد وخلقت ما يسمى بالدفاع المرن
على عمق معين يقارب 30 كيلومتر عبر
الالغام عبر الحفر عبر الخنادق وبالتالي
عبر توزيع القوى على ثلاث مستويات اليوم
من ضمن تسعه الويه اوكرانيا اليوم يتم
استعمال القليل من هذه القوى من ضمن 3
اليويه فقط اللواء 37 سبعه واربعين يبقى
عده الويه مهمه منها 117 واللواء 82 ولدين
يعتبران من اهم الالويه المدرعه اليوم نحن
في بدايه جس النبض لم يبدا بالفعل موضوع
الهجوم الذي تحدث عنه اما الخسائر التي
وقعت فهي خسائر طبيعيه لعامل لفريق يهاجم
وفريق يدافع وهذا يجعلنا نعود للقضيه التي
اثارها اصلا عندما قال ان هناك خطا في
المشوره العسكريه التي تقدمها المؤسسه
العسكريه لبوتين
الخطا هذا يجب تصحيحه الان
وقد حصل ما حصل هل نتوقع تغيير في هذا
الصدد هل نتوقع تغيير في المؤسسه العسكريه
سينعكس بشكل او باخر على الاستراتيجيه
الميدانيه العسكريه
بالطبع يجب ان نعرف من كان الى جانب
ريجوجين سيزاح من سياتي بعده وفي خضم
المعارك عاده من الصعب دائما ليلى تغيير
القيادات لانها لم تكن ولن تكون واعيه كمن
لديه خبره لفترات طويله على ارض المعركه
اليوم تغيير وزير الدفاع تغيير رئيس
الاركان امر صعب جدا وخطير ولكن تعودنا في
خلال هذه الحرب على التغيير السريع في
القيادات العسكريه الميدانيه على سبيل
المثال الجنرال سيروفيكين عندما عين في
مرحله الانسحاب من خرسون وفجاه تم الاطاحه
به فقط لانه مقرب من بريجوجين
على العموم سنتابع معك بلا شك ما يجري
خلال الايام القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك العميد
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من
بيروت
[موسيقى]
الان الى السودان افاد مراسل الجزيره ان
الجيش الصف تجمعات الدعم السريع في محيط
مقر شرطه الاحتياطيه المركزي جنوبي
العاصمه الخرطوم اما قوات الدعم السريعه
السودانيه فقالت من جانبها على حسابها على
فيسبوك قالت ان قواتها السيطره اليوم على
مقر رئاسه قوات الاحتياطيه المركزي يتزامن
ذلك مع تحليق مستمر للطائرات الحربيه
التابعه لسلاح الجو السوداني في سماء مدن
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
والخرطوم بحري وام درمان
قد تنهقهم الحرب كذلك تفعل بكل المتقاتلين
لكن لحظه الحسم تتاخر فتفتح المجال لتجدد
المعارك كل حين اشدها طلاوه في ثلاثي مدن
العاصمه
في غمرتها تقصف الطائرات الحربيه التابعه
لسلاح الجو السوداني صباحا تجمعات لقوات
الدعم السريع هناك
يتحدث الجيش السوداني ايضا عن تنفيذه
عمليات نوعيه ضد قوات الدعم في بعض احياء
ام درمان والخرطوم بحري اما جنوبا فتتصدى
قوات الجيش كما قالت لواحده اخرى من هجمات
قوات الدعم في نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب
دارفور وكبرى مدنها
للدعم كما يبدو تكتيك اخر في الشمال
يجعلها تستميت في محاولات اقتحام مقر قوات
الاحتياطي المركزي التابعه للشرطه
وجدت تلك القوات سانحه لمهاجمه المقر
مجددا خلال معارك ضاريه تدور في محيطه
جنوبي الخرطوم لكن بيانا من الجيش
السوداني الذي يخوض المعارك بالمشاه
والمدرعات وسلاح الجو قال ان قواته تصدت
لهجوم ما وصفها بميليشيا الدعم السريع على
مقر الاحتياطي المركزي فكبتها خسائر كبيره
في الارواح ودمرت عدد من العربات المقاتله
ينبه محللون الى ان منطقه مقر الاحتياطي
المركزي للشرطه تشكل خطا دفاعيا متقدما
للجيش السوداني باتجاه مناطق الشجره
والكلاكله كما انها تقع شمال معسكر طيبه
الذي كانت تابعا للدعم السريع ومنه تتزود
بالعتاه والذخيره
لكن تلك ليست سوى واحده من بؤر صراع زرع
الفوضى في الخرطوم وامتد لهيبه لولايه
شمال كردفان وولايات دارفور يدخل الاقتتال
اسبوعه الحادي عشر دون ان يتفق طرفه على
هدنه جديده تشمل ايام عيد الاضحى
انتهاك الهدن المتتاليه جعل الغموض يكتنف
مستقبل جهود احلال السلام
الجنود الافريقيه عبر مبادره منظمه ايجاد
تتحفظ عليها الخرطوم اما الجهود الامريكيه
السعوديه فارجات الى حين لانها لا تحقق
بشكلها الحالي النجاح الذي تنشده الوساطه
وفي التداعيات الانسانيه قال احمد عثمان
نائب المفاوضه العام للعون الانساني في
السودان الى قرابه 25 مليون سوداني اليوم
بحاجه لمساعدات انسانيه عاجله وفي مؤتمر
صحفيا عقد في بورسودان اوضح ان اجمالي عدد
النازحين في البلاد وصل ثمانيه ملايين
بينهم اربعه ملايين و300 الف نازح منذ
بدايه الحرب في الخامس عشر من ابريل
الماضي
تبين لنا انه قد بلغ ان عدد الاشخاص
المحتاجين الى مساعدات انسانيه
قد بلغ
15.8 مليونا منهم
ثلاثه.7 مليون نازح وهذا قبل
15/4/2023
ثم ارتفع هذا العدد
من المحتاجين المستويات الانسانيه الى
24.7 مليون
اكثر من 18 مليون بحاجه الى مساعدات
انسانيه عاجله
بزياده 57% عما كان عليه قبل التمرد
العسكري
وانضم الان الينا في الاستوديو خالد
العيسر الباحث والمحلل السياسي السوداني
اهلا وسهلا بك سيدي العاصر هنا في
الاستوديو معنا اريد ان اسالك طبعا في
اكثر من شق فيما يجري حاليا في السودان
الشق الانساني وهو مؤلم وقاسي للغايه ولكن
في البدايه كان هناك رهان على ان الموضوع
سينتهي على اعتبار ان ليس هناك تكافؤ في
القوى ولكن هذا لم يحصل اين نحن اليوم من
حل الازمه
التحيه لك ابتداء ولمشاهديكم الكرام
وطالما ان الامر ابتدا من المحطه
الانسانيه اسمحي لي ان اقدم الشكر اجزلوا
لدوله قطر ممثله في القياده الرشيده وهذا
الدعم الكبير الذي تقدمه للسودان ربما منذ
عقود مضت ولكن على وجه الخصوص في هذه
الازمه الاخيره اما فيما يلي سؤالك
الواقعه ان هذه الحرب عندما بدات الجيش
السوداني ولم يبدا هذه الحرب وكان
بالضروره ان يتصدى لهذه المؤامره الدوليه
الكبيره
واذا نظرنا الى معطيات الاحداث على ارض
الواقع والحراكه العسكري نفسه والدراسه
ميزان القوه العسكريه ستجدين ان القوه
العسكريه التي ابتدات هذه الحرب من قبل
قوات الدعم السريع كانت في يوم 15 ابريل
تتكون من عشرات الالوف من الجنود
المتجيئين بكل الاسلحه النوعيه مدعومين
لوجستين بكل العتاده العسكري عشرات
الالاف السيارات رباعيه الدفع الان نحن
نتحدث هناك انحسار كبير للقوه العسكريه
على الصعيد البشري وعلى القدرات من ناحيه
المعدات العسكريه والمؤهلات الحربيه التي
تتصل بالسيارات والمدافع المضاده للطيران
والمواد اصبحت مجموعات متفلته تتحرك بلا
قياده سياسيه بلا قياده عسكريه منذ ان تمت
عمليه ضرب المقرات الاساسيه لهذه القوات
واصبحت بلا قياده ولا سيطره وبالتالي اجمع
بها من العصابات التي لا تتمتع حتى
بارتداء زي عسكري موحد في تقديري ان هناك
كان امل كبير ان تحسم المعارك في فتره
وجيزه ولكن بالتاكيد هذه حرب والحرب لديها
معطيات على ارض الواقع سيمون الجيش
السوداني يتبع طريقه في القتال تتوخد دقه
في عدم اصابه المدنيين والاضرار بمؤسسات
الدوله ولكن في النهايه هناك ازمه حاصله
وكانت هناك محاولات عديده في البدايه هدى
ووساطات اين نحن من هذه الهدن والوساطات
ايضا لابد من الاشاره استاذه ليلى الى ان
القدرات العسكريه التي ابتدرت هذه الحرب
وانا متابع لمسيره عدد من العمليات التي
تمت في دول كبرى كما هو حال بريطانيا
وامريكا طوال الاعوام الماضيه شخص وعد
عندما يختلف جريمه داس تتعطل الحياه
العامه في هذه البلدان في لندن في باريس
تتابعين مثل هذه الاحداث في امريكا
وبالتالي 120 الف جندي هذا ابتداء اما
فيما يلي الهدن العرقبه الكود التي تواجه
الحكومه السودانيه الان من الشعب السوداني
اصبح في حاله صدمه نفسيه لا يريد ان تتجدد
هذه الهدى من جديد يريد ان تمضي مسيره
القتال العسكري اما بان يركن الدعم السريع
لقرارات القائد العام التي توجب دمج
القوات التي لم تتورط في قضايا وجرائم ضد
الانسانيه ونهب الى موارد الدوله وقدرات
الافراد واما ان تستمر هذه الحرب الى ان
تنجلي
الموقف في اي دوله في العالم يمكن ان يسلم
الجيش الوطني ارادته لمجموعه ارادت ان
تنقلب على السلطه تحت مزاعم انها تريد ان
تنشر الديمقراطيه ولكنها في ذات الوقت
ترتكب كل الجرائم التي لا تتصل
بالديمقراطيه فعلا يمكن ان تتدخل فيه قوه
خارجيه طرف ثالث بحيث توقف ما يجري على
الارض خصوصا وان الثمن والتكلفه الانسانيه
كبير جدا يعني هذا العدد الكبير من
اللاجئين اكثر من 8 ملايين لاجئ الان
اضطروا لمغادره السودان بسبب ما يجري الى
متى اذا كثيرون عملوا لهذه الحرب حتى لا
تندلع قبيل اندلاعه وبعد اندلاعه وكان
الخوف والهاجسوا ان لا هذه الازمه لما
يمكن ان تتركه من تبعات اقتصاديه وانسانيه
بالتاكيد لا احد يرقب في ان تستمر هذه
الحرب وليس هناك على وجه الخليقه البسيطه
من يرقب في ان يرى الدماء واشلاء الجثامين
ولكن بكل تاكيد هذه الحرب المفروض على
الشعب السوداني الذي هو يقدم التضحيات
ولكن هناك قوه دخيله خارجيه وداخليه
تعاونت ووضعت ايدها فوق اياضي بعض لكي
تشرد هؤلاء الملايين ولكي تعزى الاقتصاد
الوطني السوداني وتفرض واقعا اقتصاديا
وسياسيا على المدى الاستراتيجي اخطر مما
هو عليه الحال الان والشعب السوداني على
الدرايه كافيه بما يدور وانه ويصمم بان
القوات المسلحه تمضي في هذه الخطوات الى
ان تحسم هذا التمرد العسكري البديل لهذا
التمرد العسكري حتى في وسائل مراكز
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه يتحدثون عن انه ما
هو البديل هل البديل يسلم الجيش طواعيه
امره وسياده الدوله الى عصابات عبر الحدود
والبديل
[موسيقى]
نقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصادر في المعارضه
السوريه قولها ان 11 شخصا قتل في قصف شنته
طائرات روسيه على مدينه جسر الشغور ومحيط
ادلب شمال غربي سوريا واوضح الدفاع المدني
السوري العامل في مناطق المعارضه انا
طائرات روسيه استهدفت سوقا للخضروات في
مدينه جسر الشغور بريف ادلب الغربي ما
اوقعت تسعه اشخاص
ونحو ثلاثين مصابا كما استهدفت غارات
روسيه اخرى محيطه مدينه ادلب واسفرت عن
مقتل شخصين واصابه اخرين
كذلك هذا مراسل الجزيره ان قوات النظام
السوري قصفت بالمدفعيه مناطق سكنيه في
بلده سرمين ومسجد في بلده افس بريف ادلب
بالاثناء ذكرت منظمه منسقوا لاستجابه في
سوريا ان عشرات العائلات نزحت من جسر
الشغور واطراف مدينه ادلب الى مناطق اخرى
جراء القصف
في اخبارنا الاخرى افادت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه ان الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه
قررت وقف جميع اشكال الدعم المالي
للمشاريع العلميه والفنيه والتكنولوجيه في
المستوطنات اليهوديه في الضفه الغربيه
وقال مراسل الاذاعه ان مصادر رسميه اكدت
ذلك مشيره الى ان القرار الجديد يشكل
تراجعا عن قرار اداره الرئيس السابق دانا
والتي شرعت للجهات الامريكيه الرسميه دعم
المشاريع في المستوطنات
ومن جانبها علق مكتب رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو على الانباء الوارده
بشان احباط هجوم ايراني ضد اهداف
اسرائيليه على الاراضي القبرصيه ورحب مكتب
نتنياهو باحباط ما وصفه بالهجوم الارهابي
ضد اسرائيليين على الاراضي القبرصيه وقال
ان اسرائيل تعمل بشكل واسع وبطرق واساليب
عديده في كل مكان من اجل حمايه
الاسرائيليين
اعلنت مصر والهند رفعه مستوى علاقاتهما
الى شراكه استراتيجيه وذلك خلال لقاء في
القاهره بين الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي ورئيس وزراء الهند النارندرا مودي
والذي يقوم باول زياره له الى مصر وذكر
بيان الرئاسه المصريه ان السيسي ومودي
بحثات تعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه في مجالات
عده بينها الاتصالات وتكنولوجيا المعلومات
والصناعات الدوائيه واللقاحات والطاقه الى
جانب زياده حجم التبادل التجاري بين
البلدين والذي بلغ سته مليارات دولار خلال
العام الماضي بحسب بيانات جهاز التعبئه
والاحصاء المصري
[موسيقى]
يتوجه حجاج بيت الله الحرام غدا الى مشعل
منى لقضاء يوم الترويه وذلك حتى بزوغي
الشمس يوم التاسع من ذي الحجه وكان الحجاج
قد ادوا طواف القدوم لدى وصولهم الى مكه
المكرمه في بدايه مناسكهم وبدات وزاره
الداخليه السعوديه تنفيذ الخطه المروريه
لاداره افواج الحجاج الذين يتوقع ان يصل
عددهم هذا العام الى نحو مليونين
و300 الف حاج بحسب وزاره الحج السعوديه
تمر رحله الحج الى بيت الله الحرام بعدد
من المراحل هي مناسك الحج منها ما هو ركن
ومنها ما هو من الواجبات في التقرير
التالي نتعرف على مراحل الحج من الاحرام
وحتى طواف الوداع
والنعمه لا يرى الملك لا شيء
اول مناسك الحج هو الاحرام واخرها طواف
الوداع قبل مغادره مكه المكرمه يعرف
الاحرام بانه
نيه الدخول في نسك الحج او العمره على
الحاج اذا نوى الاحرام ان يدخل في النسك
قبل مجاوزه مواقيت الاحرام المعروفه
والمحدده اماكنها شرعا واما من كان متمتعا
بالحج اي انه سبق له اداء العمره ثم تحلل
فهو يحرم للحج من حيث هو في اليوم الثامن
من ذي الحجه او ما يسمى يوم الترويه يتوجه
الحجيج الى منى يمضون يومهم ويصلون صلوات
الخمس جمعا دون قصر استعدادا للتوجه الى
عرفات فجر اليوم التالي اليوم التالي هو
يوم عرفه اليوم التاسع من شهر ذي الحجه
يقف حجاج بيت الله الحرام في صيد عرفات
لاداء ركن الحج الاعظم فالحج عرفه كما قال
الرسول الكريم صلى الله عليه وسلم
يصلي الحجاج الظهر والعصر جمعا وقصرا
ويمضون يومهم في الذكر والدعاء وبعد مغيب
الشمس يفيضون الى مزدلفه حين يصل الحجاج
الى صعيد مزدلفه يصلون المغرب والعشاء
جمعا وقصرا يجمعون حصى الجمرات ويقفون عند
المشعر الحرام يذكرون الله كما امره مع
طلوع شمس يوم العاشر من ذي الحجه يوم
العيد يتوجه الحجاج الى منى لرمي جمره
العقبه يوم النحر هو اليوم العاشر من شهر
ذي الحجه سمي بذلك لانه اليوم الذي ينحر
فيه الهدي يبدا الحاج بالرمي ثم نحر الهدي
والحلق او التقصير ثم الطواف بالكعبه طواف
الافاضه والسعي بين الصفا والمروه
[موسيقى]
الى الصفا والمروه من كان متمتعا بالحج
اما من كان مفردا او قارنا فلا يلزمه سوى
سعي واحد اخر مناسك الحج طواف الوداع يجب
ان يكون اخر شيء يفعله الحاج قبل ان يغادر
مكه المكرمه عائدا الى بلاده راجيا من
الله ان يتقبل منه ويغفر
[موسيقى]
لاني لا فقره المتابعه لحصاد الليله والتي
تسلط الضوء على ازمه اقليه رونديا في
ميانمار وهي اكثر الاقليات اضطهادا في
العالم وفق الامم المتحده اذ يتكرر حديث
المقرر الاممي الخاص عن ازمات المتلاحقه
تتعلق بالتمويل وملفات اخرى
لنذكر قليلا بهذه الازمه اندلعت هذه
الازمه اثر حمله تعرضت لها الاقليه من
متطرفين بوذيين عام 2017 وصفت الحمله
بعمليه تطهير ضد الاقليه المسلمه المنتشره
في ولايه اراكان على الساحل الغربي لميان
مارك حيث هدمت الحكومه قرى باكملها خلال
تلك الحمله الواسعه تعرض روهينجا للقتل
والاعتقال والتعذيب والترحيل القصري كما
احرقت منازلهم وممتلكاتهم وفق تقرير
مفوضيه الامم المتحده
بعد ذلك بست سنوات انشات السلطات ما يسمى
القرى النموذجيه وذلك لتشجيع الاسر
البوذيه على الاستيطان في ولايه اركان
بدلا من المسلمين الروهيه بين عامي 2012
و2015 سجلت الامم المتحده ارتكاب سلطات
نيمار انتهاكات واسعه ضد الروهينغ شملت
القتل والعمل القسري وتقييد الحبك
كنت قبل الحصاد قد التقيت مقرر الامم
المتحده الخاص لحاله حقوق الانسان في
ميانمار توم اندروس سالته عن ازمه
روهينغيا وعن ازمه المساعدات الدوليه اين
وصلت
لدينا اكبر مخيم لاجئين في العالم هم هناك
لانهم ضحيه عمليه اباده مليون في بنغلاديش
وحدها لا يمكنهم ان يعملوا ويعتمدون على
المساعدات الانسانيه والدعم الدولي يتراجع
شيئا فشيئا الان نحن امام كارثه محتمله
وما الذي تفعله الامم المتحده من اجل
توفير شيء من المساعده لهؤلاء
الامم المتحده تقدم من خلال برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي غذاء ووجبات لكن المجتمع
الدولي تتراجع مساهماته هذا العام وفرنا
22% من الاحتياجات العام الماضي كان هناك
نقص بقيمه 300 مليون دولار
فشل المجتمع الدولي في توفير الدعم لهم
بالنسبه للشخص الواحد في المخيم الوجبه
اليوميه قيمتها 27 سنتا في اليوم
ساعدنا ان نفهم لماذا يبدو المجتمع الدولي
مترددا في تقديم مساعده حقيقيه للروهنجيا
في الوضع الصور مؤلمه جدا شاهدناها لسنوات
القصص كما اشرت الى بعض منها مؤلمه جدا
ولكن في نفس الوقت المجتمع الدولي هب
لمساعده مثلا لاجئين الاوكرانيين ما الذي
يجعل قضيه اللاجئين الروهنجيا
متعسره ومتعذره على الحل هذه الدرجه
هذا سؤال ممتاز جزء من هذا العالم مشغول
بازمات اخرى البعيد عن العين بعيد عن
العقل والقلب العام الماضي كانت هناك
زياده بنسبه 300
في عدد العائلات التي وقعت ضحيه مهربي
البشر بالنظر لكل هذه الظروف كان هناك في
ابريل نقص 70% من الدعم في يونيو تخفيض
بنسبه 20% نتيجه لذلك سنرى تواتر هذه
القوارب التي يحاول من خلالها المهربون
تهريب اللاجئين
والوضع سيء جدا في المخيمات في بنغلاديش
وهم ايضا مهددون
بالعوده لميار لمواجهه مصير ربما يكون
اسوا بدون اي تجنيس لا يسمح لهم بالحصول
على الجنسيه لا يسامحها باي حقوق ما الذي
يمكن ان تفعلوه مضغوط التي يمكن ان تم
حاليا هناك برنامج لاعاده الروهينديا
لميانمار وتحدثت للكثيرين بشان هذا
البرنامج
لكن هذا يعني ان تضع عائلتك في ايدي قتله
ومرتكبي جرائم اباده بدون اي حقوق او
جنسيه وهذه القوه ستفعل بك ما تشاء هذا
امر مرعب وسيئ جدا ومخيف على العموم نتمنى
لك كل التوفيق اعرف انك في جوله من اجل
جمع المساعدات من اجل هذه القضيه المؤلمه
والقاسيه جدا وزياده التوعيه واحنا نحن
ايضا كاعلام لدينا مسؤوليه بهذا الاتجاه
شكرا جزيلا لك وقرر الامم المتحده الخاص
لحاله حقوق الانسان في ميامار توم اندرس
شكرا
ازمه منسيه بعيده عن العين بعيده عن العقل
بحسب وصف المقرر الاممي كما سمعتم حسابات
السياسه وميزان الازمات العالميه لن تسعف
نساء الروهنديا في اجابه اطفالهم لماذا
نسيهم العالم لماذا لم يعد يراهم ويرعاهم
بما يكفي او لماذا هم اصلا بعيدون وعن
ماذا هم بعيدون
جريمه مروعه انا لنا ان ننتبه لها شكرا
لكم وفي منهم
[موسيقى]